مرحبًا بـ Eleni to amash ، شكرًا جزيلاً لوجودك
هنا ، رائحته جيدة حقًا
هنا ، رائحته جيدة حقًا.
العالم شركة صغيرة وفقًا لمعايير العطور ،
لكن عملاقًا في عمان بدأ في عام 1983 ،
يريد الرئيس التنفيذي ماركو باسيجلا مضاعفة
أعماله في السنوات الأربع القادمة
ليصبح بيت العطور المستقل الأول ،
الأمر كله يتعلق
بالابتكار الذي نبتكره ونستمر في الابتكار و
هذا هو واجبنا في الصناعة
كسلطة لجلب
الابتكار إلى الحدود التالية ،
يقول الاقتصاديون المحتملون في عمان إن الشركات المتخصصة
مثل أمواج تقدم رسالة مهمة
إلى بقية العالم ، وهذه
هي العلامات التي يمكننا من خلالها جذب الناس
إلى رجل و  قل انتظر إذا
اشتريت لنفسك زجاجة من المرطب ،
فلن ترغب في زيارة البلد ،
فهذه لن تكون
صناعات كبيرة ولكنها ستكون
ذات قيمة عالية ربما  ربما تكون العلامات التجارية الفاخرة علامات
تجارية ذات طابع شخصي للغاية ،
وأعتقد أن تلك هي تلك
التي سيتم تذكرها أمان ،
لذا كم عدد العطور الموجودة في
محفظتك جيدًا لدينا أكثر من 50
عطرًا مختلفًا في الوقت الحالي
وكل هذه إبداعات  حقا لخدمة
الرغبات المختلفة لأنواعنا المميزة ،
هناك ثلاثة مكونات رئيسية تستخدم في
كل عطر مدهش ، وكلها
تأتي من اللبان العماني الذي يأتي من منطقة دوفا
في الصخر الجنوبي ،
وردة نمت في
الجبال في الشمال.  أجزاء من
البلاد والعنبر مادة كريهة الرائحة
تُستخدم بشكل شائع في العطور
ينتجها الجهاز الهضمي للحوت
ووجدت مغسولة على شواطئ
رجل وهذا تقليد طويل
أشعر أنني لدي الكثير من
الأشياء  الرائحة
على الرغم من أن مظهر حوت العنبر
الهضمي
رائع على الرغم من أن أمواج غارقة في
الثقافة والتقاليد العمانية ، إلا أنها
علامة تجارية دولية مع الصين
وإيطاليا  نحن من بين أكبر 10 أسواق لها ، لذا فنحن نمتلك في
الواقع بصمة متوازنة إلى حد ما على
مستوى العالم وهذا يمنحنا
القوة للتوسع فعليًا الآن على
المستوى الدولي
خارج حدود عمان ولكن لا
ننسى أبدًا جذورها
ونعتقد أن دورنا لا يقتصر فقط على إدارة
الأعمال ولكن أيضًا  أن نكون سفيرًا
لعمان في العالم ونحن فخورون جدًا
بأن نكون شركة عمانية
[موسيقى]